there's a live shot of beautiful
downtown London a British veteran who
inspired the world with his charity walk
is getting a most elite honor last month
captain Tom Moore broke a record with
his fundraiser now Queen Elizabeth is
awarding him a knighthood after
receiving a special nomination from the
prime minister Charlie d'Agata reports
from London on Captain Tom's reaction
captain tom has just entered the realm a
knight of the realm to be exact captain
Sir Thomas More and when that letter
arrived he says he was overawed I
thought this can't be true
this said this won't happen and now it
appears it actually happen but I
certainly was never anticipated that it
would arrive for me the world war ii
veteran
captured the heart of the nation and the
world by walking laps of his garden to
raise roughly $1,200 for british health
care workers inches together there is he
ended up raising 40 million he was given
an honorary promotion to Colonel on his
hundredth birthday last month I asked
then whether he'd entertained the notion
of knighthood there's been a lot of talk
about giving you a knighthood I know
what I feel about it how do you like the
sound of Sir it's got a nice ring to it
I don't know for the moment the ceremony
of kneeling before the Queen is
obviously on hold handy with the sword
but a soul with the strength to lift the
nation for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata London he's got a lovely sense
of humor
it's so great he's getting getting this
honor Gayle
he's got a great sense of humor you can
tell he loves to play just think he
wanted to raise 1200 he raised 40
million Captain Sir Tom whatever they
give him he deserves it all